oh la la la la la la la la
mais ça m'énerve mais qu'est ce qu'il
peut bien faire ce gros lourdaud raw
françois way expérience par casimir tu
peux pas me laisser tranquille
quelle heure est il encore
ça fait au moins dix fois d'une demande
l'heure qu'il est il est deux minutes de
plus que la dernière fois à 1,4017 +2
aulas françois royer il est en retard
qu'est ce que j'y fasse mal mais c'est
pas possible enfin mais qu'est ce qu'il
fait
fally sa luge lille prend en bas il
attend le facteur parce que selon que
l'archivage doit lui envoyer un cadeau
il est vraiment trop impatient c'est
ridicule de s'agiter comme bah oui c'est
ce que je lui répète depuis tout à
l'heure et 10 mois
les facteurs rapporte le courrier c'est
que le bateau est arrivé à bien se
parler calmement alors que je te ferai
ranger mes enfants dans lequel tout
jeune et jolie julie qu'est-ce que tu
arrives à toi c'est du calme si la
fleuriste m'a dit qu'on lui apporter
aujourd'hui des fleurs tropicales
superbe alors tu te rends compte que
j'ai hâte d'aller les battre mais alors
je sais pas où mettre mon panier donne
moins envie moi ton panier jolis objets
pas rêver c'est bien elle qui m'a dit
tout à l'heure c'est ridicule de
s'agiter comme ça vous voilà
dépêchez-vous facteurs bonjour les amis
show portant aujourd'hui mais j'ai
beaucoup courrier vous avez mon collier
pour sur le vol à un drôle de bois peint
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
serrure a je crois je crois bien que
toute l'explication est là dedans tenez
françois justement julie nous a laissé
son magnétophone bons vacances à
machecoul est ce parce que j'étais j'ai
vraiment beaucoup de travail aujourd'hui
à revoir
six facteurs aubin facteurs voilà qu la
mire
oui j'ai mis la cassette dans le
magnétophone on va écouter ça on n'y va
jamais qu'est ce que c'est que gémir
c'est moi qu'on l'archipel des kits
parra bonjour on kharchi balle non
casimir il peut pas t'entendre ilc pas
qu'est ce que tu en sais et bien c'est
enregistré sur une grande écoute show
cannoise en cachemire c'est ton nom
claque sur elle oui bonjour oncle
archibald hainaut casimir t'as rien
compris
bon coup que je recommence gémir
cet oncle archibald bonjour mon oncle
archibald coûte que je ne reçois pas
idiot écoute c'est enregistré sur une
bande
c'est pour ça que je peux le faire
recommencer plusieurs fois c'est vrai
mais oui tu qu'on ne tentant pas casimir
que je recommence vous ne trouvez pas
que ça suffit de ça alors mais excusez
moi oncle archibald
mais puisqu'il ne peut pas t'entendre
enfin salon je comprends plus rien la
came here
ceci est un cadeau il s'agit d'un animal
qui sera un très bon ami pour toi merci
mais pour qu'ils appartiennent il faudra
que tu découvres le distraire de la
série le mystère de la serrure oui oui
et quand j'arrête le magnétophone et
puis j'appelle les enfants les enfants
venez avec nous venez venez venez vous
asseoir ici
kouneva ses doigts nos rivières vient
bientôt ça va
nous allons aider casino a trouvé le
mystère de la serrure vous êtes d'accord
bon on va dire alors je remets le
magnétophone en marche
casimir cinq animaux vont te parler
d'eux sans te donner le nom bon il
faudra que tu devines celui qui est dans
la boîte
écoute bien casimir bonjour j'ai deux
grandes pattes
je suis un oiseau qui ne volent pas et
qui court très vite j'ai un estomac très
solide et un long coup je vise en
afrique sur la serrure rouge g le numéro
un
alors à votre avis qu'est-ce que c'est
comme inviter chez vous vous cherchez
une série vous avez bien entendu
quel est cet animal qui a trouvé claude
sigouin tu sais c'est pas loin
anne c'est une autruche comment as tu
trouvé and we
[Musique]
elle a été grande tu as we day c'est
parfait oui c'est une autre niche n'est
pas deuxième
je vis dans les forêts françaises où je
mange des glands j'ai un cousin qui vit
dans les fermes mais je suis plus propre
que lui j de petites défense et mon
poêle et marron foncé sur la serrure
rouge
j'ai le luberon 2 c'est en millions
jean-emmanuel non c'est pas un lyon bien
triste
donc c'est pas un loup non plus les
renards c'est pas un art et mécanique
reuil non non qu'est-ce qu'ils arrêtent
une drôle de pas chercher vous l'aï lavé
petit défense
alors eh bien je vous donne la réponse
fois le rouge
c'est d'un sanglier à sanglier et son
cousin
c'est le port dans les airs c'est ça le
cousin mérite le numéro 3 je vis dans la
mer g8 de petite conne d'accueil il ya
une grosse plat sur le dos quel péché je
crache de langue retail noix ou sept
jeunes donnent souvent mon os à
grignoter aux oiseaux sur la cellule
rouge
j'ai le numéro toi on sèche mais voilà
elle parvient à trouver tout de suite
c'est une seule
comment as tu trouvé ma rigueur et là
lorsqu'on donne à manger aux oiseaux et
et l'exploit sur le dos oui ils se font
le bec des oiseaux sur l'as de la seiche
moustache on écoute la suivant je suis
le plus petit le plus gentil des félins
j'adore jouer avec les pelotes de laine
des ma langue et tout rappeuse sur la
serrure rouge g le numéro 4 alors la
pelote de laine est bien de chat qui
joue avec la pelote de laine et les
autres il va trouver la place qui manque
un peu
il a en outre appelé le problème allen
tueur et trouvez aussi et vous chez vous
vous aviez trouvé parfait on écoute le
suivant berne ces derniers
je n'ai pas de pattes pas d'elle on est
pas de nageoires province j'aime mon
roulé sur moi même pour me chauffer au
soleil là nous sans histoire je mords
lorsqu'on me dérange chez du venin on me
reconnaît grâce au v que j'ai sur la
tête sur la serrure rouge g le numéro 5
mais on ne sait pas non plus précisément
j'aurais aimé notre site web sera mieux
comment tu trouvé avec levé sur la tête
et bien c'est parfait alors casimir à
ton avis quel est l'animal qui se trouve
dans la boîte
non moi je crois que c'est une autruche
tu crois que c'est une autruche
non qu'en pensez vous mes enfants
bon sang juillet ouais pourquoi les
troupes après une jolie petite synthe et
non les petites sèche point de vue
grosser ça ça peut aller mais je crois
pas que ce soit une sèche et pourquoi
regardez bien la boîte
voilà et qu'est ce qu'il ya dans la
boîte et autres ou alors voilà ah ben
oui le chc casimir qui doit répondre le
cas gignac on l'interrogé t il
je ne sais pas alors vous pensez que
c'est un petit chat vous seriez d'accord
avec deux amis un oui mais pas chic
il restait encore la vipère désigneront
larmes ne se serait pas une vipère par
l'a1 à votre avis est-ce que c'est une
vipère qu'est ce que vous en pensez
peut-être un petit chat mais c'était
aussi une vipère regarder il est hyper
peut tenir là-dedans vous croyez que
mouloud archibal membres inrix r
pourquoi la ville terre ne pourrait pas
être dans la boîte et st micro voilà ce
que ben voilà donc donc cet achat j'ai
tous d'accord eh bien on va vérifier ça
en bio d'où vient ce soir et son petit
chat
on va regarder quelles raisons bon alors
si c'est intelligent 04 c'est la serrure
numéro 4 voilà voilà
on va regarder ces émirs si tu avais
raison et vous aussi y avoir casimir
vient voir bien voir que pour toi
approche toi
après je te rends toi et mignon non
qu'il est mignon ya là bien là bon eh
bien vous aviez tout ce réseau j'ai bien
plus touchés je peux le car et c'est
évidemment casimir crise et au chant
ah ah mais qu'est ce qui t'arrive venir
parce que j'avais je suis allergique aux
poils de chat à kazim et
[Musique]